بدلا من ان يكون على مقعد الدراسه وجد علي
نجل الاسير الشيخ خضر عدنان نفسه محمولا
على اكتاف ابناء بلدته في عراب قضاء جنين
ليصدح بغتافات تندد بجريمه اغتيال والده
في المعتقل الاسرائيلي
[تصفيق]
في بيت خضر عدنان سادت اجواء الحزن بين
افراد عائلته عقب الاعلان عن استشهاده بعد
اضرابه عن الطعام لنحو ثلاثه اشهر رفضا
الاعتقاله
الاحتلال واهم ان ظن انه قد يكسر عائله
الشيخ باستشهاد الشيخ نال اقصى ما يتمناه
الشيخ قصر كسر الاحتلال حتى وان استشهد
كسر الاحتلال انه لم يرضخ لهم ولن يقبل ان
يبقى داخل السجون كما هم ارادوا هو حر
والحريه تليق به اضراب شامل ومسيرات تمديد
بما تعرض له الشيخ خضر جابت مدن الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه ولم تستثنى المؤسسات
التعليميه من الاضراب ونظرا لما تعرض له
خضر عدنان في المعتقل فقد جاءت ردود الفعل
الفلسطينيه على المستويين الرسمي
والفصائلي حركه الجهاد الاسلامي التي
يعتبر خضر احد ابرز قادتها في الضفه
الغربيه قالت انما تعرض له الشيخ
[موسيقى]